to be honest with you in terms of what
I've I've gone through it quite quite a
lot over the last probably what seven
years maybe like bad a daughter had been
born and I I was worried about the man I
was going to be you start doubting
yourself with that then you have other
things all came to a head where I was I
was literally driving home one night
from London on a Motorway and I was just
like aimed at the end of the road and
just like let's go to me it felt like
God literally bitcha me and said get
home and I did I Lally just I can't I
can't even remember the drive home all I
remember it going really really dark
really quickly but I got I got back and
check myself into a therapy unit the
next day you can have people say all the
time oh he's good to talk you know find
someone talk to someone you know and
that's easy said to n but the best way I
describe it is and if anyone's listening
to this may understand what I'm talking
about it's you you're aware that many
people go through it but to you it feels
like you're the only one who is